Sweden's capital Stockholm becomes a
city of lights in the weeks before
Christmas there are lights everywhere at
City Hall the Opera and in window
displays at the Royal Palace gonna stun
the Capitals old town is also brightly
decorated
[Music]
the oldest Christmas market in the city
is located on stir tour yet a small
square in the old town Christmas
ornaments have been sold at the red
stalls here for more than a hundred
years rebuilding surrounding the sweet
cool so it's very Christmassy here
there's no snow but it's very beautiful
I thought it's very cold which it is so
that's why we're near the cluck-cluck is
Sweden's take on multiplying it includes
cinnamon raisins and almonds the
non-alcoholic version is also very
popular at Christmas markets cocoa
grease our typical Swedish peppermint
candy canes a baker from the village of
Greg knackered Amalia Eriksson invented
them in 1859 today they're still made
according to her recipe and by hand just
like back then the red and white candy
tastes exactly the same but the color
combo makes for a festive treat
[Music]
just one island away from the old city
is the Swedish Center for architecture
and design it's the site of an annual
gingerbread house competition the Yule
goat or urine Bach in Swedish is a very
important Christmas ornament here
christina sudden buries firmly has been
making them for generations she uses
right to make her goats because the
grass can grow quite high and it's very
robust right now and the Advent season
she's very busy
the Yule Bach has a tradition from from
the Christmas play where people go
around villages and and ask for money
and one is dressed in a goat mask and we
also have the goth or his van he swaggin
is driven by goats
[Music]
st. Lucia's day is celebrated in
churches all over Sweden on December the
13th every year the choir of Sofia
Church in Stockholm
puts on a concert to mark the holiday
you cheer was a young girl said to have
been martyred for her faith at the start
of the 4th century
she was Italian
but she's especially revered in Sweden I
think it has to do with the darkness in
Sweden at this time of year the light is
a very important symbol it's a symbol
for life it's a symbol for hope and good
deeds and that was exactly what Lucia
the original Saint did in her time
[Music]
fairy riots around the Stockholm
archipelago are also very popular in the
Christmas season on the island of here
to Holmen our visitors can enjoy a
traditional feast prepared by Henrik
Carlson chef at the theatre Holmen
ostrog restaurant the Christmas
smorgasbord is known as the Yule Ball
and features salmon and herring dishes
as well as ham every Swedish families
create their own Christmas table for a
Christmas Eve when they celebrate with
the families and they usually have maybe
15 or 20 different kinds of dishes we
have a 150 you'll board feasts are laid
out three times a day as if you had a
whole - Krog it's a festive and
delicious way to get into the Christmas
spirit
[Music]